[Musik]
more gbr fans ich bin oberstleutnant uwe
springer ich bin diesmal direkt von der
erbauer 19 befinde mich hier tower in
zeltweg die vorbereitungen laufen sie
noch vier tage bis zu eher bauer und wir
sind guter dinge dass wir euch eine gute
show liefern können hier darf ich ein
kurzes update geben über den heutigen
tag dienstag
der brite september am sechster und
siebter jetzt hier los ist jetzt schon
sehr zuversichtlich das wetter ist gut
die ist dann haben wir noch ein bisschen
sorgen gehabt wegen regen aber die
ersten flugzeuge sind schon im anmarsch
es kommen zb die spanischen kunstflieger
die patrouille ag la die werden heute
ankommen und vielleicht am späteren
nachmittag schon trainieren
das heißt alle sind bereit für die große
show unterhaltung euch weiterhin am
laufen